One example of a programming language that sits on top of such a north-bound API
is Frenetic, which is a SQL-Like query language. For example, Frenetic would
allow a programmer to count the number
of bytes, grouped by destination Mac address
and report the updates to these counters
every 60 seconds. The group by statement.
The group by statement allows a grouping
of counts by the destination mac address. Where
allows restrictions to only count trafic coming from
a web server coming in on a particular
port and every specifies that the results of
this query should only be returned every 60
seconds. More information about Frenetic is available at
frenetic-lang.org. And in the course, we'll actually going
to use a language called Pyretic that is based on the
same underlying theory as Frenetic, except that it's embedded in Python.